glenn you've lived an incredible life
a productive one but just representing
um
some powerful ideas some powerful ideals
but life comes to an end
yeah
do you think about your death
are you afraid of it
well
it is a
really interesting coincidence that
you'd posed me that question
because i'm coming from a funeral
today
is sunday
on the proceeding tuesday five days ago
i was at the funeral of eugene wesley
smith
who was my brother-in-law
he was my sister's husband
my sister leonette
passed away in august
of 2021
her husband has died at the age of 68
in
april
of 2022 and i was at his funeral
he died suddenly of a heart attack that
came completely out of the blue he
seemed to be in perfect health
he was a magnificent human being i could
go into the details but you know
take my word for it he was a businessman
a steel trader metals trader he would
buy and sell
he worked mostly from his home office he
had clients
counterparties people he did business
with all over the world
um
he had three sons
one of whom is uh in his early thirties
two of whom are in their late thirties
these are my sister's children she's
deceased now he's deceased
the older two sons are severely
developmentally disabled and although
they're
in their late 30s
they're not independently viable they
don't function effective they have to be
cared for
that responsibility has now fallen to
the family
but mainly to the surviving son
who lives and with his wife and his two
young children
and has assumed the responsibility
they've carried at home my sister and
her husband wesley eugene wesley smith
cared for their
disabled sons at home they didn't want
to see them institutionalized they had
some help from
programs at the state and social worker
and so on but they mainly took on the
burden of caring for them at home
anyway i go on at length here and you
know i don't know how much of this you
will choose to make use of and it
doesn't matter really i'm just trying to
respond to your question i was asked
to offer some remarks at the funeral
and i offered them and i you know
i i spoke well of this great man he was
a great man he had a straight back
he was a stand-up guy he could be
counted on his word was his bond he had
broad shoulders he carried a lot of
people with him business associates
family members and so forth and so on
he had a huge heart he was a giving and
kind person he had a great mind he was
an intellectual even though as a
businessman much of his day was taken up
with the
you know minutia of
contracts and you know the details of
the order being delivered and not being
delivered of the quality of the product
of the financing and so forth there was
still a powerful mind there
yeah he was a powerful mind and he uh
studied he read books he was interested
in music and art he was
uh
he's a spiritual seeker
uh had been ordained as a child minister
in his youth and while he remained
a master
of the christian canon
he also explored uh eastern religion and
other spiritual paths and
kind of stood above any particular
tradition as a man who believed in god
but thought that god manifest himself in
many ways uh to human beings and that
there was much to learn
from other religious traditions as well
this is wesley we called him wesley by
his middle name eugene wesley smith may
rest in peace
68 that's five years younger than i am
right now he dropped dead without
any warning i could too
so
how does that make you
feel what were the thoughts in your mind
leading up to it having to give that
speech in the days that followed first
of all i wondered what would i say what
would i say and you know there was no
way to prepare and i decided you know i
i rehearsed in my mind this
you know he has straight back he had
broad shoulders he had a big heart he
had a great mind you know he had a
capacious spirit and whatnot and i used
that as a template for making my remarks
but my main thought was my god life is
precious and life is fleeting
and death is a part of life
my death is a part of my life
uh and i thought you know well i want to
take better care of myself than i do you
know etc etc but i also thought a lot of
this is not in my hands at all
i thought one should have his affairs in
order
my brother did not have all of his
affairs in order in the sense that there
is a lot of
you know things are going to probate
there was no will there's you know this
is kind of unsettled i i don't want that
to happen to my
uh surviving family members i i want to
have my affairs
such that should heaven forbid i fall
over one day and don't get up again
people don't have to scramble about how
to how to take care of things from from
that point forward but as a human are
you afraid
i'm afraid now i i read this wonderful
book called the swerve
uh it's it's about lucretius it's about
uh the nature of things which is this
great classical work from the roman
period
uh by this uh guy lucretius and i'm
trying to think of the name of the
author but you could look it up the
swerve is the book it won like a
national book award or a pulitzer prize
is and it's the history of the recovery
of this book
uh
by uh one of these italian renaissance
italian
people who would go into the monasteries
in central europe
uh and uh look through the scrolls and
they'd discover these classical works
from antiquity which had been lost
through the dark ages and they re
uh publish and and and read these works
and lucretius's great work
on the nature of things was one of these
books poggio
uh
boccellini i come i don't remember the
italian guy's name but this all could be
looked up uh yeah pogio broccolini yeah
15th century
uh 15th century and the name of uh
the
author is stephen greenblatt yeah
stephen greenblack a magnificent book
and a
terrific story
anyway one of lucretius's points he was
an atheist
i mean he was a roman i mean he was
he he didn't believe in mysticism
and he and and he argued
it's irrational to be afraid of death
why should i fear death
death is coming to all of us
the point of being afraid i mean i'm
wasting my time fearing something that i
have no
ultimate control over it's irrational to
be afraid of death
uh yeah because it uh you can't predict
when it happens
you only know that it happens
so why be afraid how's that and
therefore live every day fully live
every day purposefully
um
you know
and so on but these are all just words
you know i i don't want to die
uh i want to live forever i'm not going
to live forever
i don't want to i don't want to suffer
i i see people suffering i saw my late
wife
linda dacha lowry dr linda
thatcher lowry professor of economics at
tufts university whom i met in graduate
school at mit
black woman from baltimore
we married we raised two sons together
she died at the age of 59
from metastatic breast cancer
and i watched her suffer and i watched
her die and it took a
while uh and we care for her at home
right up until the very end she died in
our bed
with our sons on either side of her
and the dog curled up by the uh by the
door the porch door
in the bedroom and she expired
and i watched her suffer and i watched
her die and i don't want to suffer who
does
i don't want to die
i am likely to suffer before i die
i am likely to see my death coming
and to lament it
um
there's a book by richard john newhouse
the theologian called as i light as i
lay dying
as i lay dying richard john newhouse
uh he had stomach cancer and uh he
thought he was dying and he wrote this
book as he lay dying
and then he recovered he had uh he went
it went into remission and he had
another couple of years he thought he
was dying and he had another couple of
years
and i can remember meeting him
at a bookstore in suburban boston when
he was on a tour
he was this was a friend of mine a
theologian and a public intellectual
he founded the institute on religion and
public life in new york city which still
exists
richard john newhouse
and he's contemplating his own death
from the point of view of a christian
minister he was a first a lutheran
pastor and then he
converted to catholicism or as he would
have put it on return to the church
because he you know thought the
renaissance was over i mean i'm sorry
the reformation
richard thought was over he says there's
only one church you know it's
et cetera
get into theology stuff here um
but
i'm saying all that to say
i read that book aloud to my wife linda
as she lay dying in that bed i read that
book
and it was filled with hope i mean it
first
acknowledged the dread
yes
i lie
dying i don't want to die i'm a
christian minister christ was raised
from the dead i'm supposed to believe in
everlasting life but the fact of the
matter is this is me and i'm lying here
and i'm dying
this is the end of me
how are you gonna do anything other than
dread the end of me so let's acknowledge
that i don't wanna die okay i'm just to
tell you that up front
but
that is not the end of
my death is not the end of life
i have lived well and fully
uh i will go and do my best right up
until the end
uh i will accept what is inevitable
uh and i will hold out this belief and
he's a christian minister so he holds
out this belief and he knows he knows
that the belief is not rational it's not
a reasoned deductive scientific
conclusion
it's spiritual in the most
fundamental way
it is something that people hold on to
and they have hope and he had hope
i don't know if i have that hope
i
used to be
but i'm no longer
um
a christian and am no longer
a theist really i i
i'm with lucretius there i mean there's
no nothing
there's no magic that's going on here
there's no you know unseen hand behind
the scene that's arranging things
what i believe is that when i look at
the natural world i see i see the
evolution of the species i see the
organic development of the of the
planets i mean the earth is going to not
exist in
a finite number of years i think with a
very high probability the sun
is going to die it's going to you know
implode it's going to go supernova
whatever is going to happen and there's
not going to be
any there there
you